[Music]
hello and welcome to
sophie ridge on sunday every adult in
the uk
is going to be offered a coveted vaccine
by the end of july that's the
government's new target anyway
it suggests that the vaccine rollout
continues to go well but with that
success comes new pressure
if so many people are getting jabs
doesn't that mean restrictions can be
eased
and life can return to normal well today
the cabinet will be signing off the
lockdown easing roadmap which the prime
minister will announce tomorrow
it will be too fast for some people too
slow for others but the challenge for
boris johnson
is to make good on his pledge that this
really will be the last lockdown
well ahead of this big road map we've
got a bumper lineup for you the labour
leader kia stammer has told me that all
children should return to schools on
march the 8th
we discussed everything from covid to
cannabis to thierry unruh in my
interview with him
in just a moment the health secretary
matt hancock will be telling us about
the new vaccine target
the archbishop of canterbury justin
welby is calling for more affordable
housing to be built
i'll be speaking to him and the former
conservative leader william hague has
urged the government to ease the great
majority of restrictions in
april we'll hear my full interview with
him later too
the former shadow chancellor john
mcdonnell will be reacting to kirsten's
speech this week and the interview
and professor debbie shredder will be
talking about that much anticipated
lockdown easing plan but first we are
joined now by the health secretary matt
hancock thank you very much for being on
the program this morning
good morning how are you i am okay thank
you well you're updating your
vaccine targets today just tell us when
people should expect to get their first
dose
we're able to now set a new target for
the vaccine rollout and the vaccine
rollout has obviously been a huge
success
so far and met all of its objectives
we're now aiming to offer a vaccine to
everybody
in categories one to nine that's those
who are most vulnerable
and the over 50s and health and social
care workers
and to do that by the 15th of april and
then
all adults should be offered a jab by
the end of july
we now think that we have the supplies
to be able to do that
we can see that the nhs and all of those
partners and all those working on this
have been able to
deliver jabs at about half a million a
day which is an incredible effort
so collectively the whole team now needs
to focus on this renewed target
of of all vulnerable groups all those
over 50
by the 15th of april and then
we'll keep rolling out and make sure
that all adults get access to the jab
as you say you're able to do this
because the vaccine rollout is going
well
there are currently around half a
million teachers in the united kingdom
you're doing around 400
000 doses of the vaccine every day
some people will be wondering that if
reopening schools is the priority
tomorrow
why not just spend a few days giving
teachers their jobs
well the question is the order of
priority
and so within that pair of targets that
we're setting today we also obviously
need to
to vaccinate and to offer these jobs
according to the order of priority
and we've asked the expert group the
joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations
what order we should vaccinate in
broadly
in order to reduce the number of deaths
as fast as possible and i think
everybody can
can understand why we asked that as the
as the question
and they've set out the priority groups
one to nine which includes those who are
clinically most vulnerable
and their carers and includes the over
50s going down the age
range and they are
currently considering after that what
might be the best order in terms of
clinical
priority and there isn't strong evidence
that
teachers are more likely to catch covert
than any other group
but i'll leave it for the jcbi to set
out what they think
is the best order in which to do this
that minimizes the number of deaths
and you know i think everybody can
understand that as the as the goal
the target is to offer every adult their
first dose by the end of
july are you looking into whether
children should be vaccinated as well
yes there's clinical trials underway as
to whether
children should be vaccinated and of
course
there are there's two points here one is
that it absolutely must be safe
specifically for children and so that is
being currently
uh investigated and the second
is because children are very very rarely
uh get symptoms or uh
or and serious illness from the disease
um
the the value the importance of
vaccinating children
is to try to stop the spread of the
disease
and obviously that's something that
we're the impact of the vaccine
on stopping transmission is something
that we have early evidence of it looks
like
the the first jab reduces the your
impact of transmitting the disease by
about two-thirds
but we need more evidence on that as
well okay now
if the vaccine program is speeding along
lots of people are going to be wondering
why you're being so cautious
on restrictions you want to vaccinate or
offer a dose
to every adult by the end of july but
you can't even tell us whether or not
we'll be able to go on a holiday in the
summer i mean that does seem
to some people you know a little bit
ridiculous
well i know that everybody at sky news
is is keen to
be able to get back to having parties
and all of us
understandably want to get back to
normal but
it is right to be cautious it's
incredibly important there are still
almost
20 000 people in hospital with covid
right now almost 20 000
and the vaccination program whilst
clearly going very well
will take time to be able to reach
all people who are have um significant
vulnerability especially because we also
need to get the second
jab to everybody so we've got a bit of
we've got time that needs to be taken to
get this
right the prime minister will set out
the road map
tomorrow and um you know he'll set out
the full
details take into account that we need
to take a
cautious but irreversible approach
that's the goal
um cautious irreversible approach and
that some people on your own side
are getting slightly twitchy about i
spoke to william hague
this week who's told me that when
everyone over 50 is vaccinated
then there wouldn't be much
justification for keeping the
restrictions on people and the top nine
priority groups who
you say will get their first dose by
april 15th they count for 99
of deaths is that the time to start
looking at easing some restrictions
well it's very tempting sophie to say
more about what the prime minister is
going to announce tomorrow
but the it hasn't been fully signed off
yet i'm going to
after after this i'm going to go and uh
keep working on the details of that
and so you'll understand why i'll uh
i'll
reserve my uh what i say on that until
the prime minister sets out the full
details tomorrow
of course i understand that you don't
want to say anything uh before
the sign off from cabinet but can you
give us a bit of guidance on schools
it's something that so many parents
across the country
and pupils as well will be watching
very carefully the target of course get
pupils back
in the classroom by the 8th of march do
you want that to be all pupils in all
schools
well that that's absolutely something
that the prime minister will address
tomorrow um i i you know i know that
i i know the importance of that and i
know from personal experience
um and um we we we also
have seen um and set out really very
clearly that
getting schools back is the top priority
amongst all the different things that we
want to do
to get life back to normal uh getting
getting schools back
is at the top of their priority list
would it be fair to say you know you're
emphasizing the cautious nature of this
would it be fair to say that you know if
you're gonna
the aim is to get schools back on the
8th of march or at least
many more pupils back in the classroom
the 8th of march
are you gonna we should expect to see
any other easing in march or would it be
safe to assume that you're going to see
the impact of reopening schools before
easy anything else well it is very
important to see the impact of steps
that we're taking
um and the reason for that is because uh
you
whilst it was you know we want to set
out a
a road map which gives people uh
guidance
in terms of you know how we think we'll
be able to do this
we also absolutely will be vigilant to
the data
on the way and we've seen throughout
this pandemic that there have been
moments when
things haven't gone as expected for
instance when the new variant was first
discovered in kent
and that had a big impact on how we had
to manage the pandemic
and we've currently seen other new
variants
that thankfully there's very very very
few of in this country
now but we've got to protect against
them and we've got to assess how
effective the vaccine is against those
new variants in particular the ones
first discovered in
brazil and in south africa and we've got
to remain vigilant
against uh against any new
new variants so all of these things mean
that you have to watch
the data but we also do want to give
that indicative
sense and the direction so that people
can start to
begin to plan their lives in a way that
we've all
you know they've all been put on hold
for the last uh
the well the last year and certainly the
last
uh the last month or so whilst we've
been in this second national lockdown
so that's the overall uh strategy the
prime minister will put the
the the details on to that as i say you
know
after this i'll be going and working on
them and then we'll have we'll finally
uh sign them off um before he announces
but but that's the sense of direction um
just before we move on um there's only
times reporting that the uk is actually
offering to
host the european football championships
this summer is that true
i haven't seen anything on that i i i
understand that that's
not right okay thank you and
you mentioned the impact of new variants
as well we know of course
that this is something that scientists
in government very concerned about what
is the latest data
on the south african the brazilian
variant well there is evidence that the
measures that we're taking
both the enhanced contact tracing and
also
the measures at the border there is
evidence that these are working
and that we've now got a much stronger
vigilance in place because everybody
coming into the country has to be tested
and we sequence the results of those
tests
and we've also got a a very strong set
of actions working with the local
authorities very specifically
in the areas where a new variant is
found and we hit it hard
and send in that enhanced contact
tracing and go
door-to-door so we've now got this
program in place to be able to
really really uh try to stamp out a new
variant where we see it
and there is evidence that that is
working uh
evidence that that's what sorry does
that mean that you think that cases
might be coming down
of those variants yes i do and we
publish data on this
uh so everybody will be able to to see
that so
there is evidence of that um but we i i
want to be cautious here because we've
got to be vigilant because
if one of these new variants uh doesn't
respond
to the vaccine as well as the others
as well as the old you know the the the
variant
uh that is now the standard variant in
the uk which is the kent variant
um the um then if that's the case
then we've got uh you know then that's
obviously a very serious
risk for the vaccination program now
we're doing a lot of work to find out
the impact of the vaccine on these new
variants especially the ones discovered
in brazil and south africa
because clearly knowing the answer to
that question
is critical to understanding how much of
a risk the new variance posed but the
good news is that the actions that we're
taking
right now do appear to be working okay
now you've been found to have acted
unlawfully
this week by refusing to publish details
of curved 19 contracts
will you resign no that's not quite
right it's important to be
clear on what this court case did
and didn't find the court case did not
find
that there was a problem with any of the
contracts
what it found is that whereas we're
supposed to publish the details of
contracts within 30 days of them being
signed
on average we published them in the heat
of the crisis
uh on average 47 days after they were
sorry to come in um because i i did i am
careful to be specific i know that
they're not talking about the details of
the contracts
that's why i said refusing to publish
the details the high court judge said
there is now no dispute that in a
substantial number of cases
the secretary of state breached his
legal obligation to publish contract
award notices
within 30 days of the awards of
contracts i mean look people understand
you have to spend money you have to act
quickly in a pandemic this is about
transparency
that matters as well doesn't it that's
right so you're
that that's right um the question that
you first asked was
about a refusal to publish that's not
true
we published the details of all these
contracts that we had to publish
absolutely and quite rightly on average
we published them just over a fortnight
later
than they should have been and there's a
reason for that sophie
the reason is that there was a global
shortage of ppe
we needed to buy ppe to save lives
and my officials with my full support
spent every waking hour buying ppe
so that even though we came close we
never actually
ran out of ppe in this country and they
did that
even though the paperwork got delayed by
on average just over a fortnight
that's what the court found and i and i
think
any secretary of state in my position
would absolutely back
back my officials in doing the right
thing
saving lives so will you now commit to
publishing the names of
all firms who are given public contracts
and how much they were paid
well of course we publish all the
details we're required to publish
and that that's been happening all the
way through the fact is
that in the heat of the uh first wave
on average we were just over a fortnight
late in some of these publications
that's what the court case found
that was put right over the summer
publishing the names and details the
question was
i'll commit to publishing what uh what
is on the standard basis what is legally
required and what is normal to publish
and and we do that um and we have done
since the summer so you know the the
the the the actual substance of this is
how quickly did we act to
buy the ppe and other things that were
needed to save lives when there was a
global scramble
and the answer is we acted incredibly
quickly
some of the paper got a little bit
delayed and i'm
absolutely backing my team who did a
phenomenal job incredibly difficult
circumstances
and we follow all of these all these
rules we follow them absolutely the
transparency is important
i agree with that and in fact in
past jobs i've had i've been responsible
for putting some of these rules in place
uh and i'm perfectly happy with how the
team in fact
i think it's quite important to stay on
the record i'm incredibly grateful for
what the team
did because circumstances were so
difficult
okay now talking about the circumstances
of the pandemic during the pandemic
women
have been able to take pills at home for
an early
abortions up to 10 weeks gestation my
colleague isabel webster looking into it
this week
without first having to go to a hospital
or clinic and
the government's now consulting about
whether to make this temporary measure
permanent now i know the consultation's
going on but do you think that this is
something that should be considered as a
permanent change
well i know that this is a a very
sensitive area
so we have put out a detailed
consultation document
people with strong views on either side
of this debate
should respond to that consultation
we'll look at all of the answers and
we'll look at what's being put forward
and then come to a considered view okay
now last time you were on the show i
asked if you'd been talking to
tony blair you very neatly started step
the question a week later
tony blair told me that yes you have
been talking and now i read in the mail
on sunday that apparently you stopped
talking to tony blair because
he's pinching your ideas and passing
them off was his own so
is the bromance over i i talk to all of
the former
prime ministers uh as you would imagine
uh because this is a very
difficult circumstance of being so i i i
i i talk to
uh i talk to all of them and uh
try to get advice from wherever i can
okay
uh very neatly sidestepped again um now
it's been confirmed this week that
prince harry and megan are going to be
uh not going to be returning to their
roles as working members of the royal
family
we sad to see this well
look i i i i know that this is
not a direct answer to this question but
the
um i'm an enormous supporter of
the royal family and the incredible work
that they do for this country
and the leadership that they provide
and um you know i'm i'm concentrating on
tackling this pandemic and preparing for
the
future and giving the nhs all the
support that it needs um
i i think that the uh i think it's best
if i leave it there
uh understood thank you very much matt
hancock for being on the program this
morning thank you
thanks for having me uh matt hancock the
health secretary there now
this week's the kiss dharma gave a
speech described by many as a re-launch
it came after a couple of difficult
weeks for the labour leader accused by
some in his own party
of needing to do more to hold the
government to account and to set out his
vision
for the country well against this
backdrop and of course with that
lockdown easing roadmap
due tomorrow i traveled to his north
london constituency yesterday to talk to
him
spring has come early to this part of
north london so what better time for the
leader of the opposition to set out his
plans to regenerate
the labour party although kirsten has
been in the thick of it through brexit
and now as party leader it's easy to
forget that he is comparatively new to
politics
i was elected here in 2015 um
which was uh what five and a half years
ago um
and uh it feels a lot longer now but
actually yeah of course it is only five
and a half years
what five and a half years it's been as
well what five and a half years
kier that's the one
yeah how are you doing how are you yeah
not too bad you're fair enough all right
and now he faces the biggest challenge
of all to win back the voters
thank you so much great nice to see you
take care thank you
party good fantastic that's good to hear
but he's operating in a landscape
transformed by the kovid 19 pandemic
the prime minister is updating the
vaccine target so that every adult
should have their first dose
by the end of july you must welcome the
news absolutely welcome this news and i
think the whole country will welcome
the news the vaccine is the light at the
end of the tunnel and
all credit to those on the front line
who've been rolling this out the nhs
have done a fantastic
job i've been to a number of vaccine
centers and it's it's very very
uplifting and i think
everybody wants to support this so this
is very welcome
so on monday the prime minister is going
to start outlining
the road map out of lockdown what
restrictions do you want to see lifted
and when
well what i want to see from the prime
minister is
um a cautious careful exit from lockdown
we all want this to be the last lockdown
so we've got to come out of it in a
measured way
but make sure that we're not back where
we started in a number of weeks or
months
so roll out slowly carefully
follow the science i would say the prime
minister publish the science i think
that will give great confidence to what
he has to say
on monday when he puts out the road map
i think the other thing is
recognize that because there will be
ongoing restrictions of some sort
businesses desperately need more support
it's one of the reasons we've said
that the business rate relief should go
on for another six months
vat should be reduced in key areas such
as hospitality
so careful cautious follow the science
and make sure the support is there for
business they've got this far
they need to survive beyond the net set
of restrictions
of course one of the really big
decisions is around schools yeah the
government said its ambition is to open
all schools to all pupils on the 8th of
march teaching unions have said that
they
are worried about that they prefer a
more staggered approach
which side is right ideally i'd like to
see all schools back open on the 8th of
march
and all children back in schools on the
8th of march i've been
worried through the pandemic a number of
people have about the impact of being
out of school has on
particularly vulnerable children and the
attainment gap is getting bigger
so ideally the 8th of march we'll have
to see
obviously where the data is see where
the science is but that's what we should
be working towards
if that means more testing if that means
nightingale classrooms
if it means other measures let's do that
because i want to get our kids back into
school
so the teaching unions who are saying
that it should be staggered it should be
different year groups
you don't support that ideally we want
to see all those children back on the
8th of march that's what the prime
minister said would happen we're going
to have to go carefully
of course we are we're going to look at
the detail and the data as we go into
those
weeks just before the 8th of march see
where we are on the infection rates
but you know i've always been concerned
about the impact on children being out
of school but you know actually i think
if we do this
together we can get through this um
another
um big issue some people talk about is
this idea of vaccine passports the idea
that you would need a passport to go
into a pub or into a restaurant is that
something that you think is a good idea
well i think it depends and it's a very
very difficult issue let me be
absolutely clear about that and i i
think people giving yes no
answers is a risky business here i think
internationally
it's probably inevitable that some sort
of vaccine passport
is going to come into being you already
see that in some countries
for yellow fever and other infections so
i think internationally
it's almost inevitable i think the
collecting of the data is important so
we need one place where the data is
stored you know who's been vaccinated
how can you access those
records etc vaccine passports within the
uk i think is something we need a
national debate about it is
very difficult to see how it would work
but
you know let's tread very very carefully
on this where are your
instincts though what what's your
instinct well i'd be very worried for
example
if we got to a situation where it was
suggested that people would lose their
job
if they hadn't had a vaccine on the
other hand i can of course see the
concerns people
have about their own safety perhaps in
their home in their teams at work etc
and that's why i really think on this
one we need a proper national debate
let's not pretend
there's an easy yes no answer because
there isn't one now you were
elected leader last april over has
dominated
absolutely everything since and there
has been some criticism
that you haven't shown enough leadership
on coverage you haven't taken enough
risks call for things
before they were inevitable i mean think
about people like tony blair for example
who
called first for the spacing between the
doses rory stewart who
at the beginning of last year was
calling for lockdowns before other
people
do you think there's been a tendency for
you only to really call for things once
they're already going to happen well
the approach i took was the approach i
set out on the very first day i became
leader of labour party
and that was to recognize that this is a
pandemic a global pandemic with huge
challenges
and i said what we would do is we would
support the government where we thought
they were doing the right thing
and challenge them where we thought they
were wrong so for example on the
lockdowns on the restrictions
we have supported the government voted
with the government on those lockdowns
and that was the right thing to do and i
think the public expected us to do that
and then we've challenged them where
they're wrong actually if you look at
probably my two biggest challenges to
the government
the first was in the autumn when i said
having looked at the
medical advice we need to go into a
circuit break or a lockdown
and it wasn't just before the government
did it on the contrary
boris johnson scoffed at the idea said
there was no way he was
still three weeks before sage
recommended it they weren't exactly
leading the debate when people were
already calling for it the
minutes were published three months
three weeks after they were written
as soon as we saw them we called for it
but the argument that
um somehow the gov was about to do it
the prime minister
scoffed at me and said he's not going to
go into a lockdown three weeks later he
did it
we had the same thing at christmas when
i stood up and challenged the prime
minister and said look this christmas
mixing
is heading for trouble he stood the
dispatch box and said to me you want to
cancel christmas i'm not going to do it
a few days later he u-turns so the idea
that we've only called for things just
before the government's about to do it
actually i don't think in fairness is
bear is borne out by
uh the examples that i've just given
okay um a really simple question for you
um
matt hancock has been found to have
acted unlawfully
over not publishing these covert
contracts should he resign
i don't want to call for him to resign
i do think he's wrong about the
contracts there's been a lot of problems
with the contracts on
transparency on who the contracts have
gone to
and there's been a lot of wasted money
and i think that is a real cause for
concern
but at the moment at this stage of the
pandemic i want
all government ministers working really
hard to get us through this because
you know whatever political differences
what the public know is
this needs to succeed the vaccine rolled
out needs to succeed
and i think in those circumstances what
i'd say to matt hancock is
you need to you know go further on the
vaccine go faster on the vaccine you
need to have a road map on monday from
the prime minister
but i think at this stage going for
people to resign is not what the public
really want to see
now i'm keen to throw forwards because
some of the big challenges are going to
be about
rebuilding the economy we're rebuilding
the country
post at the current crisis uh you course
gave a big speech this week
what should a post cover economy look
like
well we're getting to a real fork in the
road
the vaccine i think gives us that hope
that we will come out of this and then
the question the critical question
which i think will define you know the
next general election probably the next
10 years is
do we when we come out of this want to
go back to where we started
and repair what we had go back and i say
no
because what we had before this was an
economy which was
unequal and insecure and we've had 10
years of austerity and it's caused
such inequality and such insecurity for
people in the economy
so we take a different path which is to
go forward to a different and better
future where
we have a government an active
government working with business
to tackle inequality not only because
it's a wrong in itself
but because inequality doesn't work for
a good economy that's
going to be the big political choice you
say coming up and i'm very clear which
direction labour will go on this
have you been a bit disingenuous here
though because you said that the
government wants to go back they want to
build back but you've quite conveniently
missed out
the better bit didn't you build back
better
which is very different meaning well if
the government
is prepared to say that they recognize
that after 10 years of a conservative
government the model we had going in but
they do they say that they don't want
austerity they don't want to return to
austerity they recognize
the model was um unjust insecure
and unequal then let me hear the prime
minister say that that is the result of
the first
of the 10 years we've had of
conservative government because that is
their
track record and if you look at the
chancellor true it is
true it is that um they've put in
measures
and the status had to be active in the
last 10 months or so
but that's necessity that's not a values
judgment
and what the child the chancellor's
instinct is
how quickly can i extricate myself from
this
withdraw those measures not how long do
they need to be in for
and the other bit of evidence i just
throw in here is that whatever the prime
minister says about
the state and the future and levelling
up just look at some of the decisions in
the last few
months the refusal to keep the uplift in
universal credit
council tax rises um for people across
the country
and a pay freeze for police officers and
those on the front line
these are not the hallmarks of a
government that is serious
about dealing with inequality and the
insecurity that is baked into our
economy but if you if you look at the
decisions they made over the last year
you have to look at the fellow scheme as
well
you can't just say ignore the furlough
scheme that huge government intervention
that we saw but just look at these bits
look at them on the record the last year
or you don't i'm not suggesting we
ignore that of course they've taken
measures um
we've supported those measures we think
they should have gone further in various
places but that's to one side
but they've done that for necessity the
idea that this is some conversion
from the uh conservative party a way
that you can conveniently forget the
last 10 years they've
converted to social democracy i think is
completely
wrong now i'm keen to find out more
about you about what you believe in and
the kind of country that you want to
build
so early this month a labour strategy
document was linked to the guardian and
they talked to focus groups who said
that people are confused
about what we stand for and what our
purpose is and they also think that you
need to stop sitting on the fence so i
want to find out
a bit more about the real care stamina
you know banning the kind of
generalities that no one would disagree
with like fairness what is it
that you really stand for a driving
determination
to root out inequality and insecurity in
our country and our society in an
economy
and to build a better future for britain
yes i'm patriotic that was one of the
issues that was in this
report was lee of course i'm patriotic
i want to be prime minister of this
country because i want this country to
be even better than it is
now actually the whole labour movement
is very patriotic we
we are in politics to change our country
for the better you can't be more
patriotic than that and i'm
very very comfortable with it i just
wonder if it does sound quite general
still though doesn't it that you want to
build a better country that you want to
stop inequality i mean no one would
really disagree with that
would they well i don't think it's
general to say
that the economic model that we've had
for a decade
has completely failed and we need to
sweep it away and bring in something
where you have an
active government tackling inequality
tackling insecurity
and working actively with business as a
business partnership
going forward and the the
forward-looking businesses
know that the days of deregulation the
days when you don't need to worry about
the climate
uh emergency are over and actually
there's a real opportunity there
to to shape a better britain for the
next generation
that is what pulses through my veins
that's what i want to
achieve and if we can take the labor
party from where it is now to where we
need to be to win the next general
election
that is what we'll do okay i'm keen to
talk about a few specifics now just to
get a bit of a sense about where you
start stand on some of these key issues
so immigration or in the labour
leadership you promise to defend
free movement as we leave the eu you've
now dropped that pledge
well we've left the eu and three
movement is gone
is the reality of the situation and
we'll do we'll face a different
situation in 2024 because we have left
free movement has gone would you like to
have free movement well we're going to
have to have a fair and humane
immigration system and we will set out
what that is in 2024 but
free movement is gone and and you can't
flick a switch
uh on this free movement depended on
membership of the eu depended on
membership of the single market
and we're at a different place now how
about drugs do you think there's a case
for
decriminalizing cannabis possession i've
never subscribed
to that view i've when i was director of
public prosecutions
i prosecuted many many cases or my team
did
involving drugs and drug gangs and the
criminality that sits behind
and it causes huge issues
to vulnerable people across the country
so i've never gone down that
route there were some initiatives in
some parts of the country where
cautions were given for low-level crimes
i think there may be something in that
but
in principle i've seen too too much of
the damage
that sits behind drugs um for me to go
down that route so the current policy
you think is roughly right well roughly
right of course you know
there's always room for a grown-up
debate about exactly how we deal with
these cases but what sits behind
drugs is the criminality of the gangs
and you know
if i look in my own constituency at some
of the issues in relation to knife crime
which is blighting the lives of young
people
sitting just behind that are county
lines and drug running and
that's the kind of impact it has on our
society
um how about um trans issues as well do
you think that trans women
should have access to women-only spaces
such as
prisons for example or toilets or
refuges well look trans rights are human
rights
and the trans community amongst the most
abused and discriminated of any
community and we need to absolutely
understand that and have a grown-up
discussion about how we go forward
i don't think we're in the right place
on trans rights i think we should go
further than the current
legislation but what i don't want is
this
war that's going on at the moment by you
know two different groups
fighting each other in a way that we
can't make progress so you say you want
to go further in what way
well i think that if you look at the
legislation that's in place
the processes and procedures are
demeaning
and there's too many stories of how
demeaning it is that i've heard for
myself we must be able to do better than
that i have of course
um dealt when i was director of public
prosecutors with many women who've been
through
domestic abuse domestic violence
etcetera and i know
how precious some of the spaces are that
they need
um to be secure to be safe
and and therefore there are no easy
answers here and as i say just just
taking lumps out of each other
pretending there's a yes no answer for
everything i think is wrong
now just before we finish uh lisa nandy
said in an interview
uh last month that joe biden is a woke
guy whose victory was a source of hope
for labor
are you awake guy well i am what i think
about president biden is the values that
drove him through his campaign and the
values that he's putting on show
as a president and i i admire those
values i think it's a
shot in the arm for um for global
politics shot in the arm for politics
here
and i'm i'm a values-led um person and i
think that
is what joe biden is and is that a
weight guy well look it's a values-led
uh person and um just banding of words
around don't help
i'm values driven i'm utterly determined
that we can do something to tackle
inequality to tackle insecurity
um and that we can do that sooner when
we think if we
pull together as a party pull together
as a movement we obviously lost very
badly in december 2019.
i am convinced and i'm fighting every
day a week month and year into 2024
that we can turn this around and bring a
labour government in in 2024 and make
the difference we need for our country i
mean some people would say though that
you know
you say you can turn it around but we've
had 116 000
deaths related to covid the worst
economic hit since the great frost in
the early 1700s and yet you're still
behind in the polls
well look we're living through a
terrible pandemic
a year ago i was in the leadership race
to become the leader of labour party and
journalists were saying to me is the
labour party even going to
survive here so that was the challenge
put to be 12 months ago
now people are putting to me are you
going to form the next government
that tells you how far we've come did i
think this was a one year project that
we could turn around the worst losses
1935 and 12 months no i didn't
do i think competence is enough no i
don't do i think it's a four-year
journey
yes i do in the leadership election
i asked you which former labour leader
you'd compare yourself to it's a
question you're quite familiar with so
i'm going to ask something that i think
you probably haven't been asked before
you're an arsenal fan what arsenal
player would you compare yourself to oh
every time i'm asked about my football
skills i say i'd like this that or the
other
and all the guys i play football they
text me straight away and say
in your head in your dreams so i'm just
going to tell you that thierry henry is
my favorite artist but
who would you compare yourself to i'm a
midfield player in the middle of the
pitch
i like to think i'm a box to box player
which means across the whole pitch
but i now know that as this goes out
there will be plenty of people who've
played football
with me saying uh in your dreams kia
um you grew up in surrey how come you
are an arsenal fan well because
uh i've been a football fan all my life
arsenal was a team that i
first started supporting um and now of
course they're my local team so i'm a
season ticket holder and i can walk from
my house
to arsenal takes about 25 minutes and
that is fantastic
thank you very much christine thank you
uh sakis there well let's talk about
that interview we're joined now by the
former labour
shelter chancellor john mcdonnell thank
you for being uh with us mr mcdonald so
we just heard from kierstarma who said
that he would like to see
all schools open to all pupils from the
8th
of march now of course that's not what
the teaching unions are saying
who do you think is right in this debate
well the teaching unions are saying very
similar to kia that
of course we want the schools to open
but it's got to be safe
and i can't think of anyone better to
listen to
than those on the front line and that is
the teachers unions it's interesting
i don't think this has happened very
often but all the teachers union
including those who represent the head
teachers and school leaders as well as
the
frontline teaching staff themselves all
saying the same thing
so i think listen to the unions and i
don't think that's different from what
keir is saying kira is saying is when
it's safe and
if we have to have a staggered
re-opening of the schools
let's listen to those on the front line
okay you're also calling today
for a lot of the debts built up during
the pandemic to be
cancelled so how much debt are we
talking about and how would you pay for
it
well at the moment what we're finding is
well look at the figures that have come
out this morning we've now got nearly
half a million people
not just living in poverty but in
destitution and if you look at what's
coming from the citizens advice bureau
and the
the debt campaigning organization step
change we have now about a million
well just over a million in severe debt
someone said the one of the calculations
from step change was
there's about a 10 billion pound debt
that's been caused by covid
on individuals and families themselves
it's a fair amount of money
but even if we just made a start on that
let's take this six hundred thousand who
are behind with their rents and
their mortgages we're talking about a
billion pounds worth that's needed
to take that pressure off them and the
way that you do that is
well you know we lifted the debt off the
banks when the banks were in crisis
hundreds of billions were lifted off
them by taking the debt over by the bank
of england and therefore
servicing it that much more cheaply but
actually if you did want to pay for it
in one fell swoop
why not have a windfall tax on those
companies in the well the banks and the
property developers
tech companies and others maybe some of
those
cronies have had contracts during the
covid crisis as well
why not a windfall tax on them to lift
the debt
off the poorest and you know one in five
of those in serious debt
are key workers the very people are
getting us through this pandemic
so i think it's one of those policies
that's readily available in fact
you know boris johnson and others have
referred back to the period after the
second world war
rad butler as a conservative chancellor
in 51
actually introduced a windfall tax on
those companies that made vast profits
during the war and post-war period so
it's something that's been done time and
time again
i also note that you've said today there
is a time for framing speeches
and political positioning but there is
also a time to get angry and demand
immediate action to help people survive
who exactly is that message meant for
for all of us for all of us here today
framing speech during the week where he
for me you know basically saying we need
to be as radical as the
atlea government and we need to tackle
inequality as our main
central thrust of policy that suits me
fine
what we need to do now is roll that out
and i think all of us both
towards the labour front baines labor
and peace all those progressives
actually
commentators as well i think need to get
serious with holding this government to
account
and actually i am i am angry people are
suffering you know
people those in debt but also those who
are struggling to get to work have had
their wages cut
and i am angry my constituents have been
treated badly during this pandemic only
two miles down the road from here i have
heathrow limited
a company that is now doing fire and
higher sacking people
and then only re-employing them when
they cut their wages
outlawing fire and rehire as a policy i
think is something
we should all be arguing for now and yes
i am angry about where
people are living in poverty you know a
lot of those people on the front line
who are trying to get us through this
pandemic some of them are having to live
off food banks that's
unacceptable and yet this government is
now growing flicked upon many of them
another pay freeze so yeah there's a lot
to be angry about and i think we need to
hold this government to account i'm glad
i'm glad you asked hancock about the con
contracts i wish you had gone further
and asked him is it a requirement to
donate to the tory party to get one of
these contracts because that's what it
appears to be at the moment
because this vip root for these
contracts so yes i think people should
get angry
and should start demanding
accountability from this government
and demanding change do you think that
kirstama should get a bit angry then
i think we're now moving into the phase
where yes
i don't think it's just on keir's
shoulders i think it's for all of us
all of us who care about our community
whether you're a politician or a member
of the community
or yes journalists as well it's time to
hold this government to account
120 000 dead you know food banks
now having to support so many people
homelessness rising again we've got a
situation where
we never budget we've only just heard
the furlough be extended that decision
should have been made months ago the
government looks as though it's going to
hold on to
the 20 pound increase in universal
credit yet living off universal credit
is thrusting people into
well destitution as we've seen and the
figures today
we need action from this government we
need to hold it to account and yes we
need to be putting forward alternatives
now
we can't wait until the next election we
need to be bringing forward the policies
that can
provide people with hope and a vision of
a better society
keir's speech during the week framed
this debate
now we've got to drive it forward um
do you think that people who voted for
kirsten in the leadership election
thinking that he would continue on some
of the radical policies under yourself
and jeremy corbyn
may have been a bit disappointed
well look i took the view and jeremy did
the same as that when we stood down
jeremy's leader here sherida charles so
we would not
treat the incoming leadership in the way
that we were treated carping from the
sideline etc
what we said we'd do is we would support
them all we could
and we have done that and now what we
want to do is support them in the
rollout of
a radical policy program the ways in
which we
hold the well hold this government to
account in the way in which we can
present an alternative
to this government but what i'm saying
is you can't leave that until so close
to the next election
if if we've learned anything you need to
present that vision but then start
presenting the details that will
enable us to achieve that vision and
that does mean starting early rather
than leaving
it too late because you've got to win
the argument can i also say
just one word of advice as well
means winning so i didn't hear that
which you and jeremy corbyn failed to do
winning an election well the way if you
want to learn anything from us we had an
early election thrust upon us
in many ways we lost the opportunity of
bedding down and winning the argument
over the vision of the society we want
to create all the individual
policies you need to start early and
that's what i'm saying
let's get on with that now let's really
now hold this government to account
let's really now set out
that clear vision exactly as kate did
during the week that
radicalness of the athlete government
tackling inequality but let's start
talking about the alternative program
the detail of those policies
i have to say also my only real word of
advice to kiera as well let's
unite the party as he promised and that
does mean
you know giving the whip back to jeremy
corbyn let's unite the party so we can
move on
and really be an effective opposition
holding this government to account but
presenting an alternative
and also the way we are at the moment
doing everything we can to support those
people
who are suffering so much under this
government okay uh john mcdonnell thank
you very much for being on the program
this morning thank you
before we move on quick reminder do
check out the safer ridge on sunday
podcast available from lunchtime
on the sky news app spotify and apple
podcast
it's got the best bits of our interviews
plus analysis from me and my producer
matt lavender so do check that out
now the archbishop of canterbury is
today calling for thousands of hectares
of land owned by the church of england
to be used to build affordable housing
he's also calling for the government to
do more to provide affordable homes too
well i'm delighted to say the archbishop
justin welby joins us now so just tell
us what is the idea behind this report
from the church of england
the report's an independent report
chaired by mr charles r batsmat
and the uh who's had lifetime experience
in housing with a very powerful group of
very diverse
people and the vice chair is the bishop
of kensington who
uh in whose areas the gram is grenfell
tower
it's an independent report which has
worked for two and a half years and
looks at the crisis in housing the 8
billion people in inadequate housing the
poor housing
the diversity
issues that mean that people in
black minority ethnic communities have
had worse outcomes in the pandemic and
so on
and it provides great challenges to the
church of england
to the government to individuals and to
landowners it's a
very powerful report setting a vision
for 20 years of housing it's a very
wide-ranging report
as well um a list of things you want the
government to do from increasing housing
benefit to committing to more affordable
homes
how big an impact have benefit cuts had
and would you like to see the 20 pound a
week increase to universal credit
maintained
i think the the report mainly focuses
on the issues around affordable housing
and the
20 pound benefit is something that a
number of bishops have spoken up in
favor of
and certainly when you look at the
demand on food banks and areas like that
we need to try and
strengthen people who are really up
against it
but the issue today is affordable
housing not just available housing
we've uh tried to set out a vision in
the way that
was set out in the 1940s for health
we know in the health service the the
aim
is that health should be delivered free
at the point of need good health care
free at the point of need everyone
agrees on that it's cross party
it is the objective there is no
equivalent in housing
and there is no definition of affordable
housing the minister said that in the
house of lords last week
there is a need for
every part of society we talk to the
government or the
report it's not us yet although i very
much welcome and support the report
it talks to the government but it also
challenges the church and the challenge
to the church is where is your soul
where are your values do you believe
what
jesus said that you love god with all
your heart soul strength and mind and
you love your neighbor as yourself
because if you do you are going to want
stable
sociable sustainable safe
and secure housing right
across society and that's the challenge
to the church to use its land and be a
leader in this area yeah of course so
many of the
issues that people experience with
housing have just been exacerbated
in the last year with lockdowns a
pandemic meaning you're spending more
time
at home of course and you're talking
about the challenge to the church but
this is also clearly
a challenge to government as well do you
feel that you're having to step in
because the government hasn't done
enough
it's not this government this is the
housing crisis goes back
at least to the mid-1970s and
you know kathy come home uh you
you'd know of that film um uh ken loach
right back in the 60s talking about poor
housing
that had an immense effect at the time
but
we have far more people in private
rented accommodation
uh then than we do now uh
and we have far more people a far higher
proportion of the population in
inadequate housing now
than we did then and so
this isn't a about this government or
its
immediate predecessors it goes right
back through all parties and we need
a national common vision for housing and
that will be sacrificial
the report calls on the the um
church to be sacrificial not to take its
maximum possible benefit
that is the challenge that i welcome and
support
and i affirm that call and call on the
church to react in that way
and it calls on government and
landowners in the same way
okay um you mentioned grenfell in your
first answer
do you think more needs to be done to
remove dangerous cladding from high
rises
absolutely i do and that is one of the
keynote recommendations in the report
that the government the report
recommends as i say it's independent but
i support this that the
uh the the government take
responsibility for the cladding
uh they've announced 3.2 billion i think
a couple weeks ago but that
may well not be enough and then recover
that from developers and other people
okay now i just want to ask you a little
bit about coronavirus because of course
we're all waiting for the prime minister
to announce
uh the road map out of lockdown i know
there's lots of concern about
the amount of school that children have
been missing
what would you like to see tomorrow
well a roadmap is a very important thing
but it has to be
one that we can be really confident
about so if you know as well as i do
that this last lockdown has been one of
the most painful for the most
people um i go into a local hospital
as an assistant chaplain and you see
the exhaustion of the staff the way
they're worn down
we need a road map that will stop us
going up and down
and i know the government is deeply
committed to that the huge success
of the vaccine program uh speaks to what
we can do
and i think it needs to be
secure and that we know it is going to
be delivered so we can all move forward
i mean the pandemic has stripped the
paper off
the cracks which we've covered up there
there's a school's crisis because
children have missed a year of education
had it disrupted yet not all missed it
thanks to the heroism and the quality of
the schools
um there's a housing crisis which is
revealed
being revealed in its full extent uh the
health service
is desperately tired uh there is a
huge need for
a clear roadmap and i'm sure the
government is
working on that and will produce that
are they right to prioritize the
reopening of schools
i'm absolutely sure their right to
prioritize the opening of the schools
that is probably the most urgent thing
it's been the most urgent thing right
the way through i remember talking to
one of the senior medical advisors last
year he said because
the church of england educates more than
a million children
uh in its schools and he said whatever
you do
do everything you can to keep the
schools going because the damage to
children's
mental health their long-term education
is so
is so serious you mentioned the success
of the vaccine rollout in the uk and i
know that you've previously been quite
critical of
countries buying up more vaccines than
they need
at what point do you think the uk should
donate
vaccines to poorer countries so many of
which haven't vaccinated anyone at all
well the the anglican communion of which
technical senior bishop in the world is
80 million people in 165 countries
and the average anglican is a woman in
her 30s on less than four dollars a day
probably in an area of conflict or
persecution
so most of my work is is with
the very poor around the world i'm very
pleased that not only has this
government done
very very well on the vaccine program
but it's also leading the world
on the international distribution of
vaccines
and i welcome that warmly i hope that
others
follow that example bill gates has
called for that
and is himself putting huge sums of
money into this
i hope that uh across europe we do this
as soon as they've sorted out their own
problems on
basic distribution of vaccine and i hope
places like canada and the united states
do that
we keep saying this won't be defeated
anywhere until it's defeated everywhere
and certainly in many parts of the world
they need
massive support with this and we are
doing
very well on that um it's the first time
i've interviewed you so i have a couple
of other
questions if i may um you said last
summer in the wake of the black lives
matter protest that the church would
very carefully review statues at some of
its major
places of worship canterbury cathedral
or westminster abbey and then you said
that some will have to come down
some names will have to change that was
eight months ago have you
removed any statues with links to the
slave trade and do you think that's
something the church should continue to
look at
i'm really pleased that there have been
very few that needed to be removed that
couldn't simply be put in a better in
putting context and the context the
statue explained
canterbury thankfully hasn't had to take
anything down i really welcome that
i think in total something like two have
been put in museums or something uh
across the whole country and we're
talking tens of thousands
um so that that's
very very good news but we come back to
uh the underlying issue here which is
slavery and the legacy of slavery the
impact it had on so many people and so
many
parts of the world and still has on the
minority i think populations through
racism in this country
and we have to put resources in
to supporting them and demonstrating
that we are all equal
in this country that there is an end to
injustice race racial injustice among
others
in this country that's part of the
reason for the housing report
i'm talking about modernising the church
would you like to see a woman
archbishop one day
the church and people in the church be
very relieved to know that i have no
influence on my successor um i'd be
delighted i'd be delighted what i want
to see
is diversity of leadership in which
leadership is anointed by the holy
spirit of god and
in which they love jesus christ and they
love their neighbor and
enable millions of people to discover
the love of christ for them
and then just finally of course the
royal family in the church have a very
strong and historic connection were you
sad to see the news that the duke and
duchess of sussex are going to step back
from royal duties
uh i i don't comment on
uh on the royal family in public if i
have anything to say it would be said in
private
okay that is fair enough um archbishop
thank you so much for coming on the
program and talking about a very
important
report into housing such a key issue of
course
for so many people at the minute so
thank you thank you
oh just talking about housing the
ministry of housing have sent us this
statement
in response to the archbishop's report
we welcome and encourage the practical
steps that the church is taking to make
more of their land available for
affordable housing
we've delivered over 500 000 new
affordable homes since 2010
we're supporting renters by extending
notice periods and
banning bailiff enforcement of evictions
and we're spending billions of pounds to
remove
cladding so people's homes are
safe now we're going to take a quick
break but when we come back we're going
to be hearing from the former foreign
secretary william hague he's got a
message for the prime minister
ahead of his plan to ease lockdown just
in a few moments time
welcome back to sophie ridge on sunday
now we've been talking on today's show
about the road map to easing lockdown
that the prime minister will announce
tomorrow matt hancock said earlier that
it's still being worked on and when i
spoke this week to lord hague the former
foreign secretary and conservative
leader
i asked him what he wants to hear from
boris johnson tomorrow
well i think as with most people i'm
hoping to hear that
before too long the great majority of
restrictions on people can be
lifted and now he's presumably going to
say that that will depend
on the progress that is being made and
that's fair enough
um but i think if we are going to reach
the point
perhaps in april where everybody over
the age of 50
has been has had the opportunity to be
vaccinated
and the number of cases of kobed
is down to a very low level the the sort
of level we last saw
in the middle of the summer last year if
both of those things have happened by
some time in april
then there wouldn't be much
justification for keeping most of the
restrictions
on people i think with one big caveat
there has to be a deal as it were
between the government and the people of
this country
that we have to do the mass testing when
we reach that point we have to be ready
for really
rapid ruthless local lockdowns
we have to all join making a test and
trace system work which it can do once
the
infections are at a lower level so
everybody has to be psychologically
ready for that
and if they are then i think at that
point the government can really release
most of the restrictions and back in
june
you said that lockdown was a disaster
for our society an economic
catastrophe and so destructive that it
can only ever be allowed
once logged as i explained when i wrote
that
article represents the failure of other
policies it's what you do when
every other means of containing a
pandemic has
failed so that means you don't have
effective test and tracing
that you haven't managed to seal the
borders that you haven't managed to
identify through testing the the rise of
the virus
again it's a policy failure really to
have
a lockdown but of course coming in
through 2021
we ought to be in a position with the
development of mass
testing with a test and trace system
that can work
at a lower level of uh infection and
with the huge success of the vaccination
program great credit to the government
about that with all of those things
well then we do have the tools now to
prevent
future lockdowns i think there are
lessons
now you know and some of them we've just
been talking about
we must have mass testing well that that
couldn't have been developed last summer
um but it can be put all put in place
now
uh the test and trace system has
struggled
but it's partly struggled because
there's still such a high level of
infection to deal with and i think we
have learned that if we
are going to have long terms you have to
do them quickly that the faster you take
the action the better
so when it comes in that this um
whatever point it is later this year
that i was talking about but the
government says well you're free of most
restrictions
but we have to be really ruthless and
quick
if the virus rears its head again in a
particular town or city
or locality uh well then they have to be
ready to act
very very fast on those situations or
on um the risk of the virus coming back
in again with a mutation from
overseas talking about the way that
number 10 has handled
the crisis do you think there's been any
improvement since the changes
of personnel the departure of dominic
cummings and lee kane you haven't always
been the biggest fans then
i think that has been a big improvement
actually and
i pointed this out recently uh i'm not
one for i don't i don't want to
personally attack the people who left
they were brilliant people but maybe
running
government wasn't their greatest skill
compared to running campaigns
uh well now some people have been
brought in who are very good at running
government you know though the prime
minister has a new chief of staff
he's made other recent appointments and
it's it you can
tell over the last couple of months that
government has
worked better there's been more
under promising and over delivering
rather than the other way around
there have been fewer rows there have
been fewer destructive
leaks and side briefings to the press
you can just tell you can smell it that
things have improved and the way things
work can come and the public can smell
it as well
one of the big challenges ahead of
course is the budget what would you like
to see
in that budget well the big task for the
chancellor has been
keeping as many people as possible in
work and the economy
ready and intact for the future over the
last year and i think he's done that
very well what is the next task well the
next task is for britain to be at the
forefront
of what i think will be an extraordinary
decade of innovation
coming up uh all over the world this is
partly a result of the pandemic
partly the result of a technological
race going on between the the us
and china i think a really important
thing to look out for
in the budget is is this country
positioning itself
for that wave of innovation are we going
to have the right
rules and laws and incentives and
cooperation between
government and the private sector and
the right tax
rates to achieve that it's very
important not to disincentivize people
uh to invest in the businesses of the
future
you know people talk about reforming
capital gains tax well
there may well be some very important
and worthwhile reforms that can be made
of it
but it's really important not to tax
people away
from entrepreneurship from risk taking
from investing in things that might fail
uh in the future
as well as all the things that are going
to succeed so
um it's the chancellor's job to work all
that out
um you touched on some of the kind of
global challenges that i'm quite keen to
talk about and
particularly china what kind of
relationship do you think we should be
looking to create
postcoded with china there's obviously
these concerns about human rights abuses
should we be tacking towards the eu
position which is obviously
has china as one of their biggest
trading partners or should we adopting
the american stands more concerned about
china
well if you put it that way i would say
more the american
stance but it isn't just a
straightforward a choice
uh as that i think the eu for instance
made a
mistake signing their new investment uh
treaty
with agreement with china just before
the biden administration came in without
consultation with the united states
we actually need western countries to
put their heads together much more on
policy towards china and hopefully
when the prime minister hosts the g7 in
cornwall later this year that sort of
thing
will be on the agenda and can be
achieved but what is the right approach
well i would say it's a hard-headed
approach
it's neither um one of um it's not the
golden age of friendship but it's not
unremitting hostility either it is an
approach where we say
well we can't allow ourselves to be
dependent on china
for key technologies in the future and
that means we do have to restrict
some of the investments they've tried to
make in this country or the takeover of
british companies
by chinese entities we do have to make
sure for instance all the
the batteries for instance that we need
for electric vehicles in the future
aren't made in china so that we're
dependent on that supply chain
but at the same time we can't solve
global problems without china
we can't stop the next pandemic uh we
can't
stop climate change we can't have arms
control we can't
deal with a future financial crisis
without working with china
facebook has blocked news feeds in
australia
now this is in response to this law
requiring tech giants to actually pay
news providers for content do you think
facebook has got this wrong would you
like to see other countries adopting the
australian model of asking tech giants
to pay
news providers for content um social
media companies like facebook
have done a lot of good of course in
connecting people up
in in absolutely revolutionary new ways
and the many human benefits of that
but there's a lot of harm taking place
as well
and that harm includes to the to the
fabric of democracy
uh diminishing for instance uh local
newspapers and traditional news
outlets whose diversity and whose
availability is
is an important part of a free and
democratic society
and particularly feeding polarization by
adjusting news so that it suits the
individual
so that it reinforces the uh the views
of that individual rather than exposing
them to
wider views so yes i hope other
countries including the uk
will take a similar position we talked a
lot about some of the really big
challenges
and you know facing us at the minute
whether it's china
covid social media companies and
one big thing of course on boris
johnson's intray is
scotland and the challenge a potential
referendum could cause how concerned are
you
about the prospect of scotland voting
for
independence if there is a referendum
and if there is then boris johnson's not
going to be the person to
lead the campaign for the unionism well
i'm very concerned
about that um i can tell everybody
having been the foreign secretary
of the uk that british standing
in the world the influence of the
british people including the people of
scotland
in the world if we were to break up the
uk
would be very seriously diminished this
would be um
a bigger event than than brexit it would
have
a bigger impact than anything whatever
your views on on brexit
on the standing of the uk on our ability
to exercise our influence
in the world we are much more than the
sum of our parts
so i think this would be a catastrophic
development
we got kirstarma on the show at this
weekend as well
um obviously of course there are certain
challenges at the minute for labour is
the government's enjoying a kind of
vaccine
bounce if you like if you've got any
advice that you'd give to a leader of
the opposition who is
grappling with a newly elected
government off the back of a landslide
election
it's a very thankless task unless people
think you're about to become
prime minister and people will try and
push you around
all the time uh and and try to
we've just seen this with the speech
that kiersta ahmad gave the last
few days uh try to over hype what you're
about
to say this is a relaunch you know and
then you end up taking part
accidentally in a relaunch of yourself
and then of course everybody's
disappointed and a few weeks later you
have another relaunch
and you end up looking a bit ridiculous
um
so i think sometimes it's better just
keep your head down for a bit if the
government's doing well
and let that wash over you and still be
there
when the atmosphere has changed um thank
you so much for being on the programme
uh mr hager it's very interesting to
talk thank you
thank you very much lord william hague
there with a bit of advice for kirstalma
well let's return to coronavirus and the
plan to ease lockdown
that the prime minister will announce
tomorrow we can talk now to the chair of
global public health at edinburgh
university professor
debbie srider thank you so much for
being on the programme
um the prime minister of course laying
out his plan
for look now and easing tomorrow how
cautious do you think he needs to be and
what do you think can happen
well the thing to say is there's light
ahead and we should be optimistic
because of the vaccines as a medium to
long-term way out of this if we look at
israel
we are seeing that once they have gotten
down to vaccinating those in their 20s
and their 30s
they are seeing actually that numbers
are falling and so there is a way to
suppress this virus
and to stop severe disease with our
vaccines however
we are far way off from vaccinating
people in those age groups
hopefully as the health secretary said
by the summer so the question is how do
we ease restrictions in a one-way
process we don't see a third wave over
the next few months while the vaccine's
rolled out
and that requires a strong test trace
isolate system
especially supporting people in
isolating who are testing positive
as well as mass testing to really hit
higher prevalence areas
younger children in scotland and wales
are going to be returning to school
tomorrow return to the classroom
tomorrow it feels like in england the
ambition is to get
all schools back to all pupils on the
8th of march
who do you think has got the right
approach well
i'm obviously biased because i advise
the scottish government on their
education policies and so
i would agree what we've done here which
is tomorrow having the younger kids go
back
and to assess after several weeks what
has been the impact on transmission
what have we seen in schools and we were
learning from denmark who are ahead of
us several weeks and who also have the
new variant
the new variant is creating uncertainty
which means we need to go more
cautiously
so there is a huge risk with bringing
back all kids at the same time and then
having to shut schools again and we're
trying here to move slowly to move
cautiously and
get kids back as many kids as possible
but in a slow
staged phased way and with testing the
other thing i'd mention and it's an easy
win
for i think england is in scotland we
have allowed children
under the age of 12 to play outside in
groups up to 13. only two adults can be
there but children can play in groups so
we've seen children doing sledding
tennis football out in parks and this
gives kind of outdoor play and also a
form of kind of physical education
and that is an easy win because we know
transmission outside is minimal and the
mental health benefits are huge
um you talk about the um vaccine rollout
going well
and we heard just a moment ago from
william hague who said that once
everyone over 50 is vaccinated the top
nine priority groups which we're
expecting by mid-april
he says there wouldn't be much
justification for keeping restrictions
on people
once this group is protected given they
make up 99
of deaths of covid it does feel to many
people i suppose that
there is a good case for lifting
restrictions
yeah i think we all want to lift
restrictions as quickly as possible
i mean i'm craving going out to a party
or somewhere outside my home but i think
the thing to remember is what gets us
with this virus
is the hospitalization rate and how many
people are susceptible
and the hospitalizations do go down to
people in their 30s and 40s
which means that is what we're really
going after of course the deaths but
also the hospitals being full and not
being able to provide
routine care for all the things we need
the nhs for and so i'd say
of course we want to lift restrictions
but it has to be down to the prevalence
of the virus have we got it low enough
to testing positivity are we testing
enough finding cases
as well as are we actually vaccinating
those most at risk of hospitalization
and learning from other countries such
as israel they once they vaccinated
their over 60s they found a lot of under
60s in hospitals too
so we have to be kind of realistic of
what it's going to look like for the
next few months
and what does the data show on the
impact of the vaccine are we starting to
get any
indication yet that it's having an
impact
yes i think we're definitely seeing a
reduction in deaths in older age groups
you know people in over 80 since that
group has been covered
over 70s and we know i mean to tell
people i mean a year ago we didn't even
think we'd have a vaccine and now we
have
several and the effectiveness is
astonishing especially of the mrna ones
and so we are in a strong position to
stop severe disease
and even it seems like glimmers of hope
for stopping transmission
so i think where we're heading with this
you know people say when is the pandemic
going to end
well there's a real chance to drive the
numbers super low using vaccines using
outbreak response
and then it's time for britain and along
the way to look across the world and say
the pandemic will only be over if we
look at
poor countries fragile states you know
130 countries don't have any vaccines at
all right now
and so it's a dual responsibility both
at home but also abroad
i mean you mentioned 130 countries
without any vaccine which clearly has
big implications for the global fight
against covet
but at the same time many people in the
uk would say that we shouldn't give
vaccines away until
every adult has had at least one dose
what do you think the right thing to do
would be
this is a really tricky one and i think
it comes down to three arguments why we
have to be
vaccinating at home but also looking
abroad and the first is a moral one
is it right to be vaccinating people in
their 20s and 30s here when you have
health workers dying
in africa because they can't get access
to a vaccine the second one is actually
self-interest
we know that this virus will mutate we
have seen mutations in south africa and
in brazil
which can reduce the effectiveness of
our vaccines so if we want to be open to
the world and have people coming in
then we need to make sure we're actually
you know watching out for variants
coming in which will emerge if there's
uncontrolled spread of the virus in
other places and the third is we are
seeing russia and china
donating their vaccines to low-income
countries for clear geopolitical reasons
and so we've heard you know now with g7
um
going on that actually you know there is
concern about what will it mean for the
influence of european and north american
countries
if china and russia are seen as being
the most reliable support rather than
the western world okay debbie schroeder
thank you very much professor devi
shredder there
thank you we've got just enough time to
go back over some of today's show
with rob powell our political
correspondent um
on today's programme the house secretary
matt hancock was pretty tight-lipped on
the government's plans to ease lockdown
labour leader sakia stamina said all
school children should return to classes
on march the 8th
and the former conservative leader
william hague urged the government to
ease the majority of lockdown
restrictions by mid
april well let's bring in rob powell
shall we apologies rob we've really
squeezed your time here
uh because of the number of guests we
had on the programme um
it felt felt like today was a microcosm
of the challenge for the prime minister
tomorrow some people are going to think
he's going too
fast some people are going to think he's
not going to go
fast enough including many of his own
conservative mps too such as lord hague
and it's a bit of a tight rope isn't it
it is yeah and it's about an hour's time
boris johnson and his senior ministers
will be meeting
uh to sign off uh that will to finalize
at least that roadmap i think there'll
probably be a cabinet meeting tomorrow
to sign it off
uh you're right matt hancock was pretty
tight-lipped i thought the most he gave
away actually
was playing down the idea that this will
be a definite road map that pubs will be
open on this date you'll be able to do
this on this date
he talked about it being quite
indicative and about there being a sense
of direction but about
the government needing to study the data
as they go along so i think a suggestion
that everything boris johnson says
tomorrow
will be heavily laden with caveats that
this will only happen if the data goes
with the right direction
i think schools the big schools
announcement for the 8th of march
will probably be the same and that
whilst the ambition will be to get all
pupils back on the 8th of march i think
those caveats
might eventually see that promise walked
back slightly
it was interesting i thought to hear
kirsten say that he
would like to see all schools open to
all pupils and then of course you had
john mcdonald saying actually he agrees
with the teaching unions even though he
tried to say
kirsten the teaching unions were saying
the same thing i'm not completely sure
if that
really flies but it does feel like he
has got backing
across party for getting children back
to school
yeah kierstarma was clearer and maybe a
bit more explicit than i thought he'd be
on that actually backing the prime
minister's ambition to get
schools back on the 8th of march
education unions have said they want a
staggered approach they've said it's
reckless
john mcdonnell saying that he thinks the
education unions
are i've got it right on this one but
saying he doesn't see a difference
between what kirsten was saying
and what they're saying there is a
difference between what they're saying
the education unions are clearly saying
they want a phased approach
sakira stamina is taking exactly the
same tone as the government and saying
we should try and get everyone back
but we should be led by the data i think
this is potentially one part of the
unlocking road map that may not be so
cautious
trying to get all schools back i think
the risk
the more minor risk is that it slows
everything else down but i think the
government and the public can understand
that
the bigger risk is if they get children
back into school
the infection rate soars and then they
have to close them down again that would
be very
very bad news for boris johnson and a
bit of time to wait for hairdressers rob
yeah unfortunately never mind
fortunately the hairspray shops are
still open
uh thank you very much for the analysis
uh always good to talk thank you
well that is it for the take uh this
week a very busy uh program and of
course
looking ahead for that key roadmap from
the prime minister
tomorrow thank you for joining us and
see you next sunday hopefully we'll have
a bit more detail
by then